Great, so let's move forward and
understand where we position
ourselves among our competitors.
But first we need to
analyze our competition.
Now, there are four levels of market
competition which we use to assess
our competitors in the industry and
how we are placed in the industry.
So, the four levels of competition
are product form, product category,
generic, and budget competition.
So, let's go through this
with a tangible example.
Let's take flavored water a.
This is a lightly flavored
water without any added sugar.
Competition at the product form level
will include products that have
the exact same features and
similar values as our product.
So a competitor at the product form
level would be flavored water b.
This is another flavored water,
without any added sugar,
just gives you a little
extra kick to your water.
Now, product form competition
is extremely narrow.
We only consider products that
are actually the exact same,
just different brands.
So both of these waters are flavored
waters without any added sugar,
they just are different brands.
Now, product category
competition includes products
with similar features but it's a little
bit of a bigger scope than product form.
So an example of that would
be flavored sparkling water.
Now,, this is also flavored
water that doesn't have sugar,
but it's a sparkling water.
So, it's a competitor
on the category level.
Now ,thinking about our
flavored water example,
I want you to consider your own app.
Who are your competitors?
Now thing about product
category competition and
product form competition.
What competitors do you
have in these areas?
Now fill in each competitor's
name in the appropriate field.
If you don't have your own app to use,
feel free to use a Embarkment.